la chronique culture qui se poursuit de
nouveau invité avec nous charles
gonzalez bonsoir vos côtés céline nova
teint de la maison de la poésie bonsoir
alors vous vous produisez ce soir donc
c'est la première représentation
vous présentez une trilogie c'est celle
de trois femmes alors camille claudel ce
soir demain nous aurons thérèse d'avila
après-demain sarah kane et samedi le
triptyque à la suite d'affilée trois
heures de représentation
alors ces trois pièces s'appuie sur les
écrits de ces femmes aux destins
particuliers
j'ai envie de dire c'est quand même
surprenant vous êtes un homme et vous
interprétez des femmes c'est pas un peu
déroutant ça quand même
oui mais ce sont les origines du théâtre
je veux dire l'époque de shakespeare les
les hommes jouer le rôle de femme et
puis j'ai apporté sa dieu du japon de
tokyo où je jouais là-bas et puis j'ai
chaud qu'en voyant les zones magath à ce
sont les hommes qui jouent les
personnages de femmes et
je répète une pièce si je me suis je
mettais en scène en fait à l'origine une
femme de la comédie française dans le
rôle de camille claudel et en revenant
je me suis dit hop je vais me mois
interpréter ce personnage à la japonaise
voilà cl ça surprend pas le public non
ce nom parce qu'ils sont avertis
évidemment mais non je crois c'est au
bout de quelques secondes on oublie
c'est un homme qui joue c'est la magie
du théâtre voilà mais est-ce que vous
pouvez nous présenter justement ces
figures féminines
d'abord c'est camille claudel la figure
mythique l'amante de oui la maîtresse de
rodin aux amours tumultueuses jusqu'à la
folie l'internaute d'internement de 30
ans suite à thérèse d'avila notre sainte
espagnole
thérèse d'avila qui crachent ans le sont
jusqu'à 20 de sa vie et défis des
monastères et et des chaussées les
carmélites enfin réforme le carmel et
ensuite sarah kane cette hauteur de
anglaise qui se suicident
malheureusement en 1998 sous margaret
thatcher à londres
pour cause de menace de censure de ses
oeuvres et qu'il est ce une simple pièce
admirable voilà qui sont joués dans le
monde entier voilà pourquoi avoir choisi
ces trois femmes parce que c'est les
trois formes de théâtre camille claudel
demont pour exercer le théâtre de
l'émotion
thérèse d'avila le théâtre de la
spiritualité et
verhaegen le théâtre de la cruauté mais
on rit aussi beaucoup est-ce que c'est
pas sombre très sombre mais vous avez
faut se battre contre cette idée
aujourd'hui que le spectacle doit faire
à tout prix un rire le public mais aussi
émouvoir dont et l'émotion est aussi
fait partie aussi de du sourire vin vous
la sélune matin vous aviez déjà la
maison de la poésie accueilli charles
gonzalez
oui oui on avait déjà accueilli charles
en 2009 pour déjà camille claudel qui a
donc déjà été joués à la maison de la
poésie et le chant andalou en 2011 sur
les textes de leur cas donc voilà il
nous étions aide à la création sur ce
spectacle mêlant la poésie pourquoi
avoir fait appel à nouveau à cet artiste
parce que c'est une belle histoire entre
la maison de la poésie et charles
gonzales donc on est toujours très très
content de le recevoir les les gens sont
très contents de venir leur voir ou le
revoir en tout cas pour camille claudel
pour ces soirs et voilà c'est un théâtre
qui touche l'équipe de la maison de la
poésie qui touche jacques fourni dans sa
dans ses choix de programmation
donc ça paraissait normal de
l'accueillir et en plus sur la trilogie
donc avec les trois figures est la seule
à la soirée de samedi où là on accueille
charles pour pour une grande soirée
alors vous êtes acteur metteur en scène
où vous sentez peau est ce que justement
vous jouez à la maison de la poésie
oui vous savez des acteurs sont des
poètes finalement l'épousé du plateau on
se sent c'est une autre forme d'écriture
la folle d'écriture du corps mais nous
avons le les mots des autres
donc c'est une forme de recréation à la
de repos et zizou à la sardine est à
d'esprit-là wendel de monter sur sa
formidable dans formidable vraiment j'ai
hâte d'y retourner tout en étant très
joyeux avec vous et de parler de deux de
ses trois bébés finalement mais qui se
joue depuis très longtemps qui ont fait
le tour du monde
c'est depuis 2001 finalement camille
claudel et voilà je suis très heureux
aussi de revenir voilà la maison de la
poésie de 50 ans donc plusieurs dates ce
soir vendredi
je dis aussi vendredi et samedi il reste
des places
il reste des places pour quelques places
pour ce soir pour demain et vendredi en
revanche pour samedi ses complices est
complet
dépêchez-vous d'y aller ce soir si vous
nous suivez en direct il est presque 19
heures et on va vous laisser repartir
pour cette maison de la poésie à
guyancourt merci à tous les deux merci
également à johanna pour cette chronique
culture on vous retrouve mercredi
prochain bien évidemment c'est la fin de
cette édition du 7 8 demain en début
d'émission dès 18h en direct je recevrai
medef et cfdt patronat syndicats qui
multiplient les réunions pour trouver
des accords autour de la réforme du
marché du travail avec un contexte et
des licenciements
c'est particulièrement compliqué
vont-ils y parvenir on le verra en tout
cas sur ce plateau excellente soirée à
demain